Z
[Silence]
salamu alikum
allahar
[Silence]
as
Sal
[Silence]
f
ill for
[Silence]
alhamdulillah has given us another
blessed opportunity to come to his
Masjid to come to his community and to
be together with Prophet wasallam said
says that from to is a means of
experation of sins and great greater
opportunity than this than the holy
blessed month of Ramadan so we thank
Allah subhana wa tala and we say
alhamdulillah for these blessings that
he has given
us the prophet sallallah alai wasallam
he lays out such beautiful principles
that give us success in this world and
success in the Hereafter and the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam he begins
this narration by saying that the one
who is successful is the one who
has he has completely devoted his heart
to IM and to Allah subhah wa taala
meaning what meaning that this heart
that you have it's a vessel and it
only has such a certain amount of space
where you can't just keep feeling it and
filling with different things from
outside no rather it can only be filled
with the love of Allah Prophet s
and anything extra coming into it will
have an effect and will not allow this
heart to be completely devoted to Allah
subh waala so then continues and Allah
he makes this person's heart
what he makes this person's heart free
from any bolt free from any hatred free
from any jealousy free from any dislike
where Allah talks about
ibraim when came to talk to Allah that
he had such a heart that was free from
all these different things
and he mentions that to his children he
gives these his children beautiful
advice where he says
that that oh my children do not be
individuals that are so quick to
critique so quick to say something bad
that when something small happens that
the first out of their mouth is not
something that's very appropriate or
very kind but rather be individuals
whose hearts are completely full of the
love of Allah subhana wa taala the love
of his prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam and such a heart that is full
of IM and full of light and he continues
and he
says that such a tongue that whenever it
speaks it speaks the
truth and this may seem kind of obvious
but rather the tongue is the exposer of
the
heart where what was the quality of the
Hypocrites right was that they would
speak what was it in their heart they'd
say something on their tongue you know
to to go this way but their heart would
be going that way this is how they were
so this this this tongue of theirs was
not a truthful
tongue and then he
says that this person their soul is such
that it is a pleased Soul right right so
a successful person is who their their
their NPS is pleased pleased with what
with the remembrance of Allah subhana wa
tala and seeking the pleasure of Allah
subhah wa taala that is a heart that
is and this is very interesting because
the prophet s alaihi wasallam is giving
us
this understanding of what it means to
have a tranquil heart where so many
individuals today they search for so
many different means so many
stimulations so many just you know
dopamine rushes just to make themselves
feel a little bit happier or feel a
little bit you know find some
contentment but in the end it's just
momentary and it's not something that
lasts forever and it's very interesting
because the Allah in the Quran he
says that man was created in a state of
worry and
anxiety this is what our natural state
is meaning what that we have to make an
effort on our heart to make it such that
it is going to be pleased with the
remembrance of Allah subhana wa tala so
there has to be an active effort on this
that when a baby is born into this world
the baby came from the mother inside the
mother it was so you know everything was
taken care of it had so much love it had
all the the nutrients that it needed and
it was in this environment that was
cultivating itself and allowing it to
grow then it comes out into this world
and babies when they come out into this
this world they come into the State of
shock there's all these people there's
all these lights and sometimes
situations where the baby is not even
breathing and this is how we come into
this world and this state of how we
begin our life in this world can be the
Perpetual state of our life if we are
not working on ourselves and making an
effort on ourselves so the prophet talks
about he says that this person they
resolve and their disposition
is it's on a straight path meaning what
meaning that this person you know know
this person will not go
to one statement a person may say to
them now they don't know what to do with
their life they watch one real they no
longer want to chase that passion we
have individuals that because of you
know they're they're so distracted they
forget why they got that job in the
first place
they forget why they were in school they
had all these dreams and aspirations and
when they get there they get so
distracted it's oh what am I doing
here and then they start to make bad
decisions that will have consequences on
their life forever in this world and in
the next
World and in even a smaller situation
where a person you know sometimes may Lo
lose a phone or lose a wallet right away
they speak to oh where is everything
where did it go they come into a state
of anxiousness and worry and then they
find it oh they feel better but but
really something so small got you so
worked
up made you that angry made you that
frustrated how can that be that means
there's something that the the heart
that the heart needs effort the heart
needs work on and so the prophet
says and even to such an extent where
sometimes we get so
distracted that you know you hear like
young people that they're still you know
in high school or early college talking
about
retirement brother you think get or
sister you need to get a job first right
then you can think about that but focus
on what you're doing right now focus on
what's in front of you focus on the task
at hand if you're going be that easily
distracted you're probably not going to
be able to accomplish what you meant to
do and you may accomplish it but it's
not bringing the results that you wanted
so it's very important to have
this have this firm straight path this
is in the and the where theam is telling
us that when someone comes to you and
you hear a doubt of some sort a doubt
about a verse or a narration this
shouldn't cause you to completely lose
your faith or
Iman it's okay sometimes you have
questions go ahead seek the answer for
it ask for help but it shouldn't put you
completely off the path just one desire
one desire completely takes you off one
desire makes you forget about the mercy
of Allah one desire makes you forget
about the Forgiveness of Allah subhana
wa tala how can this be
and it's very interesting
because he writes
this in which he talks about the purpose
of every
human he says that I've studied and
looked at all the people The Young and
the old the rich and the poor the Muslim
and the non-muslim and I noticed this
theme across the
board what is this that every single
person is chasing or their purpose in
life and he said for every single person
it's removal of worry or anxiety for
example or discomfort so for example a
person they become
hungry and now the only thing I can
think about is when am I getting my next
meal a person may be with their friends
they're hanging out they're having a
good time but then a friend does
something inappropriate or says
something inappropriate now this person
has the choice to either speak
up right or allow that behavior to
continue but he thinks to himself oh if
I speak up maybe I'll lose my friends or
maybe it's not that comfortable so they
won't say anything because why it brings
this discomfort and this is
why was you know someone who was so
great because one of the things he used
to say he used to not just do it he used
to say I love it he
says that I will speak the truth even if
it's sour even if it's uncomfortable and
even if it make make the other person
uncomfortable I'm going to to speak up
right and for us this is more so also
about what makes us uncomfortable in
when it comes to relationship with Allah
[Arabic recitation]
that sometimes those first steps may be
a little difficult standing up a lot
fasting doing these different things
they can be
uncomfortable right but after some time
what happens as the prophet wasam
says then this person begins to
enjoy and they are motivated by virtues
they're motivated for Good Deeds but
nothing motivates them more than the
pleasure of Allah subhana wa
T and so the prophet wasam continues and
he talks now he talks about okay what
are those things that may have an
influence on us that maybe you know
we're not accepting it or maybe a little
bit in denial he he says that the person
who is successful he continues this now
he said the first the person who is
successful is who makes their heart
completely you know devoid of anything
else and solely for allaha T and their
faith now he says that the successful
one is the one whom Allah subhana tala
gives his eyes the ability to see and
his ears the ability to
hear well isn't that what they're meant
for aren't the eyes intended to see and
the ears are intended to
hear okay what else the prophet wasam
then continues he says what is the
ear he says that the ear is a
funnel the ear is a funnel and if
for example if you want to pour you know
some oil into some kind of container
right this vessel that you know is is
Big at the beginning and it gets smaller
when you're pouring it in it's able to
take everything in the prophet describes
our ears as a funnel meaning that
whatever is around it is going to come
in that whatever that whether we it
or not the things that we hear will have
an effect on
us and this has been proven time and
time again on the studies of the
subconscious that whether a person
recognize it or not the things that they
listen to and the things that they take
in will have an effect on them taking in
a lot of you know sad you know things
that you're listening to or or or
tragedies all the time it's going to
have an effect on your mood and vice
versa as well well and then he mentions
that when you see something as well
whatever you see it's going to travel
into the heart and it's going to place
itself
there it's going to place itself there
so now when you say that oh it's not
something very harmful I'm just watching
a small video or I'm just listening to
something small something funny but know
that it's going to have an effect on you
and those things over and over again
will change the status of your heart and
something that we have that's so
precious is our attention so when the
prophet says the eyes are meant to see
and recognize the signs of Allah subhana
wa tala they're meant to see and
recognize the blessings Allah has given
us so may I thank him and they are meant
so that we can see and understand that
there is no life worth following or more
important than the life of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi
wasallam and then the eyes of the same
thing and the ears are the same thing
that all these vessels to the heart are
some are things that we must take
advantage of and take care
of and then the prophet sallallahu alai
wasallam he mentions
that which means
protected it's very interesting because
when it comes to the things that we take
in and our attention and how easily we
are distracted there was a psychiatric
study done in 2020 in which individuals
were placed
in meditation sessions for several
minutes they're required to sit in a
room on their own and meditate no phone
no technology no other humans with them
it's just them on their own and when
they did this for several times they had
very interesting results and these are
individuals that are from this country
and whether you want to accept it or not
we are here so we will be affected by
these things as well and so the study
came out to show that these individuals
33% developed a high level of anxiety
27% developed some form of depression
and 6% developed some thoughts of
wanting to hurt
themselves why because when we're in a
state where we're always distracted we
don't know what it feels to be in
the
present and this is why it's so
important that we take care of ourselves
take care of our attention when we talk
about our Salah our is to develop a
level of such a level of that inside our
Salah we are connecting to Allah subhana
waala and not just that our extends to
outside of Salah when we're fasting in
Ramadan every moment that we remember
that hunger that pain that little bit of
discomfort that reminds us our purpose
and what we are doing and all these
things are so precious and need to be
taken advantage of and this is why the
prophet ends this long narration where
he says
the successful one is not the one whose
heart is protected rather the successful
one is the one who's always in a state
of protecting their heart meaning this
is a Perpetual state that a person is
consistent
upon that a person is in a state of
worshiping Allah coming closer to him
until the end of their life this is not
something that I'm doing for one month
for one day for one year this is
something that I'm actively working on
and also accepting the fact that at
different stages in my life I will have
different
Temptations at different stages in my
life I will have different struggles and
circumstances at different stages in my
life I have different
celebrations but know that I'm always
making an effort on my heart to come
closer to Allah subhana wa
tala brothers and sisters there is a
billion dollar
industry that is designed
to grab our attention they used fancy
terms user interface or making the
application easier but all these are
meant to say that who can keep your
attention the most and their industry
designed to do this and so much so that
now our attention has a tangible value
to it has a monetary value to it so we
have to accept that we have to make the
effort to take back our attention to not
ourselves allow ourselves to be
distracted to allow ourselves to come
closer to Allah subhana wa tala and I
want to end by giving example of the
Prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam from
his life you the prophet s alaihi
wasallam we know that when he received
Nua that he was calling others to Allah
subhana wa tala day and night and he
made such an effort such an effort that
when this Revelation first came to him
he went to of course his supporting
and loving
wife and said let me take you to my
my my cousin and my family
member was an individual whom he was
always in search of the truth but he was
someone who practiced the Christian
faith and so when they come to him and
they they they present to him the
situation that I've been visited by an
Angel and I have been given the word
that I am the final prophet and then
there is one none to be worthy of
worship except Allah subhana wa tala he
said that what did he say to him he said
I hope to be there when your
community kicks you out so that I can
support
you and the prophet he's so confused
says they're going to kick me out of the
community these people trust me they
give me their wealth they allow me to do
ar ar arbitration they allow me to help
them and they know my good qualities me
really and he says and says to him just
the prophets just Moses that
came before you and they were kicked out
of their Nation the same will happen to
you and the prophet
wasam how do you respond to news like
this supposed to be glad
tidings and his own Community his own
people that he loves his family members
they're going to do this to
him and Allah subhana waala he gives him
the anecdote for this he gives him that
that what he needs to hear so that he
protects himself and what does he
say he talks about that when we opened
up your chest and we cleaned your heart
from all that filth and all those things
he
says that when you are free and you are
done doing all the obligations and tasks
that you are required to do
f f literally means to pour something
out to pour something out so Allah is
tell our beloved sallallah alaihi
wasallam oh messenger of Allah pour your
heart out to me that when you're going
through all these difficulties when
you're going through these struggles
when you need something more and you
need an answer call on to me and I will
be there for you and the and the thing
about the prophet alam's life is that
what was he doing all day he was calling
everyone to Allah subhana wa tala day
and night so now he go call to Allah
again so how is it for us where we have
responsibilities and tasks and things
that we're doing throughout the day what
are we supposed to do now we need to
understand how precious our attention is
and that before we sleep at night that
we are pouring our heart to Allah
subhana wa tala and not allowing some
organization some app some other person
take us away from Allah subhana wa tala
and making that that the that
relationship
strong especially in this month of
Ramadan where we have the opportunities
to call call upon Allah subhana wa tala
so we must understand that the
successful one is the one who takes care
of their heart and the one who is always
in a state of protecting their
heart alhamdulillah I I am a visiting
brother from Detroit Michigan and I come
to you with an a request that
supporting our school in Detroit our
school it has an institution where we
make we develop we have a sevene Al
course program and our students also
graduate with a high school diploma and
this is happening right in our backyard
currently we have over 200 students in
our school and they are boarding
students as well they they come in they
stay there they sleep there they get
their or their course education and they
get their secular academic
education we need help in terms of
sponsoring our students we have out of
200 students that we have 70 of them are
on
sponsorship and these individuals we
don't reject people based on their
financial status we take it all based on
Merit so if someone meets the
qualifications for merit we accept them
right away no questions asked but some
individuals do need that assistance and
for each student it is $6,000 a year
this includes their lodging this
includes their food and this includes
their education both in the secular
studies and the
studies this comes out to $500 a
month which may be even cheaper than
your child at home currently and so we
do this why because we try to you know
cut off the fat and make it easier for
students to come to our school and so we
are looking to sponsor at least 10
students from this community M we are
told this community is very generous and
they love to engage in
s these students will be
the future of our why because we want
individuals who have the knowledge and
strong Foundation of Islam and also able
to excel in the worldly efforts
alhamdulillah I myself graduated from
this school and I also was able to
finish my masters in physician assistant
studies working in Psychiatry and this
is off with the of Allah subhana waala
and when I was growing up I was always
thought I had to go somewhere else but
if I go somewhere else how am I going to
do my studies here how am I going to
pursue a different career but
alhamdulillah the option is open here so
please we ask for your support we're
going to have a table outside you can
simply give some cash you can simply use
the card or fill out some kind of pledge
form but please it's something that you
can help with with our school and this
will be a for you that on the day of
judgment all the efforts that they make
will go into your good deeds
[Silence]
mam
Allah
[Silence]
for forbb
make the rose tight leave no
gaps fill in the Rose in front of you
[Silence]
allahar alhamdulillah
a
[Silence]
for
for Sam Allah
[Silence]
Allah
allb
allar alhamd
[Silence]
am
for for
[Silence]
allar allb
allb
allar e
[Silence]
asum
my dear brothers and sisters Salam
alayum the as I was mentioning last
night the best gift that you give give
us right after Juma is a few minutes of
your time and that is going to be
generously rewarded inshallah because it
will help
us talk to the people about getting some
donations for our wonderful program RMA
Academy brothers and sisters as I have
been mentioning the rahma academy is the
future of our children in
Tucson and we have a beautiful program
that has 71 kids enrolled at this point
with the 12 member staff alhamdulillah
we are making tremendous
progress the
40% of the funding is provided by the
state different programs another 44% or
40 yeah 44 45% % is provided by the
dees and the people you know but there's
a significant amount that you are paying
the through the tuition program that
that you are paying the tuition as a
from the parents but 15% is a shortfall
that we have so for that 15% we are
requesting you to see if you could help
us so with that introduction I would
to request who would to raise
the hand for 10,000